all right so I don't know if this
version is the truth of the previous
verses the truth or that's both the
truth is in truth it's girl web of lies
yeah I'm incepting good with the kick
all right this is for Steven this is a
furious beast on Instagram I'm gonna
paraphrase this question because I
really want to know this why didn't you
kill Nicholas I want you to kill that
guy so bad I want you to kill that guy
so bad and he totally deserved it time
and time again he was almost saying
please kill me I'm a complete douchebag
I want to die and at the end she somehow
found some humanity immersing why did
you not kill him really hard Scotty
unwise never even thought about that
scene to his soul uh goodness you know
um glad is a better person to me I i
also said why why did you not kill him
but it's a very it's a very complex
situation it's it's it's layered in the
sense that you know it's glenn is seeing
a version of himself in him Glenn also
realizes what it means to cross that
threshold Glenn also sees in that moment
that he has one that he has he has it
serves no function in that moment to
kill him it's not like he's making him
an example for others it serves no
function to kill him except for himself
and if he crosses that threshold I think
he looked into his face and saw an
earlier version of himself another
iteration of himself if you were to live
within these walls and he saw what he
could have been and for him it was a
chance at hopefully having him be
redeemed but at the same time I think it
was mostly Glenn trying to save himself
as well because if he crosses that line
it's kind of game over for him his MO at
this point is he got he found a place
where him and his wife can
can and compete it can can live there
can search for the life that they've
always wanted and part of that also
includes human it includes living the
life that they previously had which is
not some well but westward if someone
crosses you the wrong way you killed him
granted he shot him and shoulder but
like I said Glenn is a really good
person and then you stuck his finger in
the bullet hole big you up yeah inlet
for one together go over the warehouse
to individual I was in the house you
know shoes of the house I just picked up
this you guys were at that cocktail
party he double-dipped dance goodbye and
with back as a little horse usually kill
them for that someone York revolving
doors it isn't like punch it doesn't
isn't much revolving doors for you he it
is a complex situation but ultimately I
think um Glenn was trying to save any
part of the old world that he could and
that includes his own human does Maggie
keep him tethered to that world I think
they both have that together by the way
uh Lauren couldn't be here and she loves
all you guys and she could be your cuz
she's visiting family but know that she
loves every single one of you so um but
yeah absolutely do feel like Glenn and
Maggie keep each other grounded they
have a very symbiotic relationship and
they've overlap on many things and one
of those things is to preserve what
semblance of sanity and humanity that
they have so that they can end together
in a safe and new world together this
next question is for Lennie James this
is from yeah
Lennie James first times the walking
dead cast on a panel I have to say the
thing that was so wonderful about your
character in scenes come back is from
all the seasons would always say I'm
having a Morgan you know when you were
just a slimmer at the beginning and
people always said where's Morgan and I
think in our heads as fans we were like
he's out there somewhere and then we saw
you and clear you were like he's not
doing well but it definitely showed a
dimension or at least at least maybe
even a little bit of foreshadowing about
what can happen particularly for Rick so
what what do you think he was doing this
whole time out there but what do I think
Morgan was assaulted you know he was
painting he was getting to know himself
um I think he was and what we may find
out this season what Morgan's been and
I'm doing with himself but one of the
things he's been doing this trying to
find Rick and and at the end of the last
season he finds him and kind of wish
that he had yeah I think we're going to
find out where possibly where Morgan's
being and wanting to be done to this is
from an Alison loveland on facebook what
kind of effect do you think Morgan's
presents will have on record oh I don't
know to be honest I think Morgan and we
have a particular kind of man love that
kind of goes on and keep going
I think the fact that Morgan has gone to
find Rick I think one of them I've said
it before but it's one of the things
that's most important is really the last
person left on the planet Morgan but no
small everybody else who Morgan knows is
gone and the only man the only person
left that Morgan knows his Rick and
that's why he goes to find him and I
think Morgan's aware of the effect that
rick has had on him I don't know now
because they meet at such a kind of
important moment at the end of the last
season and this season is going to be
for now the next questions for Chandler
Riggs the Chandler Riggs welcome from
Bremen Reese one on Twitter giving Carl
feels at home in Alexandria oh for sure
yeah I think I think Laurel like I think
he sees Alexandria as a restart button I
know just to try and start over and live
the life way the way like life should be
lived you know that's that's how he sees
Alexandria I love that just that moment
with those with the other kids there or
there sure there's like video games you
like what have you people been doing
this whole time I mean you have even
just in your short time in that world
you're already a soldier basically so
how do you think he's processing how do
you think he was able to process like oh
it's okay to be comfortable again oh and
that's that's why kind of like when in
the shot when he walked into that room
and it was just like late like it was
years ago now i'm back to back when the
apocalypse started and i think for him
you know personally he sees their
vulnerability and although alexandra is
a safe place people still no need to
know how to survive in case there is a
threat outside the walls enjoy CeCe's
their vulnerability and no sorry oh no
good and is it off you're not meet you
go
yeah and so but I mean he does he has
sympathy for the kids living Alexander
and he wants to show them how lightly is
outside the walls this is from Matt hash
actually how do you think Michelle would
feel about Carl sneaking out of the
gates following Enid and we ask it you
either of you actually I'd love to hear
you both tackle that okay you going in
well oh ok so I think Carl CZ natives as
another survivors she's the one person
in that place that gets it and gets how
how it is upside the walls and so you
know he can always say relate to her and
that's why he enjoys going outside the
walls and just hanging out with her but
you know obviously being outside of
Alexander isn't very safe so I don't
know I don't know how they react if
tomorrow was running around with Enid in
the woods probably yeah you know but I
mean I think there's the thing that
Michelle really loves about about Carl
is that he has such a survivor
instinctive he's so smart and he knows
how to take care of himself so well and
so she was always just able to kind of
relate to him like like a friend which I
think the idea of him going outside
there is like you can't imprison him
it's been one sense like can't say you
may never leave these wall I think that
she would find that to be a
disrespectful way of treating him but at
the same time you know her her gut
instinct her once for him with horse are
keen extremely safe at all times so she
wouldn't she probably just hug no but
she wanted on the same time well they're
also just teenagers in the apply link
doesn't matter like if you're it if
you're a teenage boy and there's a
teenage girl even if you're like oh my
god there's zombies at the gate of
teenage girls like let's go out there
he'd be like jelqing like there's no
it's like this whole concept of you're
still human beings like you're still you
still do things that human beings do
this is a really great just a really
quick answer for this one with Chandler
at highest Laurie's wants to know if
season five Carl and a chance to tell
season one Carlson advice what would it
be um what I want I don't know really I
think just I don't know because it is
sure when he would tell him a little
kill the walker in the Swamper kill ya
and shoot you the one and shoot the one
walk or they used to the shop yeah yeah
way to make me feel bad about that all
right person who martin marine from
twitter exercises break that last season
which you portrayed amazingly she says
parenthetically what do you hope she
finds in season six oh my healing
restoration can't reach at this point
that's a great question you know yeah I
mean she's hit rock bottom you know it's
um it's been an honor for me to betray
PTSD in honor of those who have suffered
from it and that's that's what you hope
you hope that there's light at the end
of the tunnel you hope that you can
cross over to the other side and find a
reason to live again and I just live a
thrive and so that that's that's what
I'm hoping that she finds is is a way to
respond correctly to the death of her
most loved ones because looking back on
it she were to get to that place that
that yield place she would look back and
see that I didn't respond correctly you
know I have not been the woman that you
know my brother really knew and loved
and insisted that I still was I
not been the woman that I fell in love
with I haven't been the woman that even
you know our father raised me to be and
so now it's time to actually pay homage
to their to their lives and their
memories and live with hope the way they
would have wanted me to it the way that
they did the sex questions from Melissa
McBride from at ello Sydney on Twitter
what does Carol's biggest challenge in
hiding who she is / what she is capable
of from the Alexandrians what's the
biggest challenge between between being
able to basically concealing your
identity because carol was amazing i
mean the chameleon transformation to
just immediately like just an innocent
house mom and a sweater like we was
instantaneous she saw the situation she
is best who she needed to be in that
situation and she adapted like that and
so what was the biggest challenge do you
think for her in in maintaining that
persona you know I think just not having
her cover blown um she had William order
hard to do you know finding out who
these people are when they're capable of
what they're not capable of I think
really just the biggest challenge was
was keeping her cover um yeah this is
from matt deezie and dps we didn't need
to see Carol reactor tyreese's death
what did it mean to her does she miss
him despite everything there's an echo
I'm sorry we need to see Carol reactive
she said we didn't get to see Carol
reactor tyreese's death so what did that
mean to her and does she miss him yes
she misses him
every death is heartbreaking and it just
fuels the fire even more to become
stronger fight harder to keep everybody
safe including herself and everything is
fueled buying the locks of people that's
why she's doing what she's doing she
can't stand around and watch people die
you know and he's ready to pay the price
go to hell whatever she doesn't know
knows to do whatever she can to try to
help what is that what keeps our going
the need to help people yep I mean she's
not at home blooded killer she just
wants to keep going so she can you know
come face to face with something else
you can put down maybe won't intersect
with somebody and I can ya know for
Michael Cudlitz right from this is
amazing twitter name at hate doughnuts
when do you believe your characters
defining moment was hmm that's a great
question miss defining moment is yet to
come this look says the crime my degrees
thank you your night just went to live
in a world where Carol bakes cookies and
use flowers to everyone
this is from an epic ride TWD publix
what do you admire most about Abraham
what's your favorite favorite quality I
think just as pure honesty it just is
what it is you know there's no there's
no filter there's no agenda there's no
nothing going on behind the scenes it's
kind of you know what you see is what
you get in it you don't like it that's
too bad nice even he does get
that but he does get the best written
dialogue yeah on the show for sure every
time you get the scripts and you see
things that Abraham says they're always
they're always great the last of the
line you had in 16 years I yield oh
about about was gonna remember the
lines he said it so well I hadn't
recorded for us it was was great yes he
is the best pilot I just like your new
guys kind of tell me it was that
had to do with Sam fan chillin there's a
vast ocean of yes then you people
don't know about the grip knows
every fine grain of
that's all Michael there who's Diana we
were not like rolling around the like
the the writers room with that yeah like
that's that's Michael taking two words
and making them into an epic film I
think it was about partially my fault
because when he said it was so quiet in
that scene and he said it's so loudly
the wheel Wow when they're 17 actors on
set there's a scene going on and they
put you way way way in the back you want
that in your have to deliver line you
weren't that far in the back you're
gonna cut that into the last shot of the
season finale Utley lamb and just got to
come as host a Norman Reedus this car
man Jenny on geo is there anything
special that you do to get into
character for Daryl a lot of motörhead
company it's a candy crush a lot I
actually do believe that Carol would
have been ten Dara wanna join candy
crush I'm so into it as for dangerous
and I spent hundreds of dollars out and
well after you just said that out they
don't said yourself they're no
thank you yet you got so many lives on
that I played forever and then second
part to that question Jenny wants to
know what's your favorite emoji I like
the red balloon i beez do it yeah except
my questions
okay you know i do it before we go to
audience questions long time review on
instructions i do it one serious run for
you from at immortal dixon on twitter
which is the darkest season for Darrell
in terms of acidity of morals I mean
here that wants to hotel that was to
time okay which which is the darkest
season for Darrell in terms of his
sanity and his morals of season yeah
Jesus um u.s. Brooke yeah we can we can
do more in mojang questions you know I
mean there's it changes all the time
maybe the first one I kind of found them
the kids are in the first scene that I
was on and then I started to trust these
people when Rick says I'll go with you
to find your brother and I was like okay
and then that took a while and I
remember like literally handed Stevens
handbag that was fun Council um what it
help changing and where we ended up last
year when Morgan comes back with us
Briggs she's my dude in the head um we
had that scene you know just before that
where it was Carol and Rick and I you
know they says you know if this town
can't can bend a little bit which is
going to take it so I was thinking and
Daryl says when he comes back and he
shoot them in the head like it's on
let's take the town so I mean there's a
little bit of darkness all over the
place that pops up all the time
it just needs a red balloon emoji candy
crush eyes I swear to god damn camera do
seem like hey y'all maybe we should just
play some candy crush they don't have
that yet in their world bank present
yeah so lauren cohan just sent me a text
that she wants me to read their plays
turns dear correct you're the greatest
thanks so much for reading is that no
doubt loud now can you please pass it to
Steven to read Oh for real she wrote
steve says this I missed not being there
with you all at our sixth comic-con I'm
with my family right now but my other
family is at this table and in this room
we may have already said this today but
everyone in here is who makes the show
and inspires us to new Walker kill
emotional rollercoaster fighting for
life and love Heights every season and
we thank you and love you so much I hope
you all have a freaking incredible
weekend can you say something funny at
the end
then please give the phone back to Greg
what Greg actually did you actually did
bring something to show people that was
a little extra did you I did did you
paint well it seems like we're having a
blooper right now here Greg we are yeah
so what could it be then we're having a
real blooper about let me oh maybe
there's cliffs of people that didn't get
their lights right or pro characters why
this some pot now we we leave every
every year at the wrap party you know
few episodes that I'm directing when
when characters do something funny you
know the show is always so serious so
anytime we have an opportunity to do
something a little like I always tell
Amy lacing strip supervisor think mark
that is a blooper and at the end of the
seasons wrap party we screen the blooper
reel for everyone and it's it's really
just a great emotional release to laugh
with our characters and see them I'm not
particularly afraid of anybody moment is
true here Stan they should be afraid of
us yeah set very important takeaway I
think I should be very mission they
shift and concern for us while we did
what do you think Abraham woke wolves
are mega burger bring in
Devil's can hide yeah that's true i mean
wolves are nerds they're sentient beings
like they makin hunt itself in walkers
just yeah you know so i would say I'm
more concerned with the living in the
dead yeah also hey good to see you boy
what is your name madam my name is
Viviana um I just wanted to ask em their
what did it feel like being back on set
did you feel nervous I all are excited
well I'm I think we're all we were
already time to come and come back on
the show for the new season you know in
some it's great to be back working on
the show for most of my life you know
all I don't throw up but no it's um it's
fun I I love this show excellent thank
you hey man what's your name I am Daniel
order to ask who's going to be the next
cast member from the wire for the wires
compares to rob a question okay we yeah
i'll just say we tried first like I'm
not going to do Robert Griffin we tried
for someone this year and actually
didn't work out but there was i'd say we
went through the dead cast yet actually
would you want to look at another can do
you want to make that ass yes if you
wanna make this announcement ready oh
yes yes so in addition to Corey Hawkins
is he yeah but we never eat which was he
was in the trailer we're really excited
too late
episode and we've cast Merritt Wever as
a character from economic we left the
weight find out who all right next up
Merritt Wever as needed yes that's
obvious uh yes ma'am what is your name
is Jillian um and I guess this is more
directed to Andrew and deny but I find
Ricky me sean's interaction is
fascinating and I wanted to know what is
he Shawn to rheank @ present because it
kinda seems like she's only one who can
check him so it's just that is very true
yeah my mom I just want to say that my
mom is desperate for Rick and Michonne
to get together she'll be watching this
now should be very happy that I'm saying
this but she goes when if you had a
political balls you've got to get those
together she gets away she gets quite
fired up about it that's not I'm not
campaigning Scott no no again I've
received calls from your mom I agree
yeah Michonne is a fellow warrior he
respects her so much you know and
they've been through so that so much you
know I didn't he trusts her with him
with his life and with his children's
lives and so I think that yeah like many
of the characters now there are certain
sort of finance her five or six that he
looks too and he can't be checked by its
she is certainly one I think for
Michelle and I mean she he was actually
the person who checked her in the very
beginning like so clear and even before
then when she just she was kind of bug
while and she just bought the governor
and he's going to kick her out that
whole moment where she knew she had to
change is because he checked her and
that caused an indelible respect that I
think just keeps reverberating through
their friendship so let's hump a button
lady hi thanks for any of horse after me
um my question is for Karl Papa and
Chandler not this last season but the
season before you had a very very
intense scene I was wondering if any of
your cast under escape any advice for
that if you had closed set because I I
don't know many young actors know of
many young actors who could have done
the scene that you did it was amazing
did you get any help and did you have a
closed set was it the scene with you're
not sleeping okay um I mean it's I don't
know I just do it I just say the line I
do it
we gonna hit let's mature men on the set
right here all right no um no but it's
hard for those intense scenes like that
I've had a lot of them throughout
throughout the years and it's it is hard
doing those teens I think we've all had
pretty pretty intense intense scenes
along those lines and I mean it's just
it's just one of the things one of the
things you just got to get through and
and pull yourself through it thank you
but very high what's your name well
there is enough having quick kiss
between to certain people um that was a
little bit unexpected because everyone
is expecting that certain girl to kiss
another certain guy um but I just wanted
to know with that kind of an intense see
how do you believe the awkwardness of a
sea like that on set canoes you the
question a little vague i think that
there's this girl was she was showing
she took a bronx even throw ya
yeah he's dead he's dead it happens in
show sometimes I let it you unless he
comes back as a walker interested hi so
you're asking what's it like to kiss
somebody on set and leave that on set no
maskeen how do you relieve the
awkwardness of doing in Tennessee oh how
do you believe the audience are doing an
intense scene the kissing part was a red
herring oh wait I'm so confused oh the
blooper reel i think was pretty
self-explanatory with that kind of thing
because there were so many intense
scenes but it seems like that there are
moments where they kind of break out of
it a little bit and their own because
everyone seems to be you know family
basically it's kind of at some flights
into sort of breaks down like oh we're
just sort of screwing around with our
friends and we're safe and you know
under laughing or at you know even want
any punches of always like oh my god I'm
sorry those are those kind of moments I
think relieve the tension whoever one
snaps back into reality in a second if I
guys have to get back into it every
would have to wear you all feel crazy
and this is you know there aren't a lot
of horror shows that go on and on and on
in this cast the thing that blows me
away is that these guys live a horror
movie every week and they've been doing
that some of them for six years and then
there's a bit of a psychological cost
for that yeah an eighth one will
continue to do so for many more years
that's the plan that'll be
I'm just telling you until I can keep
working I don't know and the
psychological toll that Chris has its so
you know what there is a psychological
never realize that I would be America's
damn selfie therapist when your favorite
character dies of the first stupid face
you see and I feel responsible you tell
us come on I mean what do you got for me
I need more drama I talked them dead one
thing everything's okay it is it is
funny like finishing an edit of
something like really heavy and we go
right to the end of the rail and you
just picture Chris like stepping out in
the appetizer it's gonna be all right
torches crazy stuff or something sure
you're ruining the show we have it
Terrell yo hey Darrell Darren what is
your question because I just want to say
that you always do an amazing job my
question is for my hero Norman Reedus Oh
Thank You Norman that makes me feel
great
you can always bring me up on stage shoe
that's cool nice Tweel your signature on
in management or between beyond send you
that picture okay so what's your
question question is for enormous what
kind of character development can we
expect to see in season six for Darryl
first up did you just call me enormous I
did maybe that was a freudian the minute
you stood up I knew I liked you you
better send that guy a balloon deluging
what that was dandy customer to start
that Monday yeah before this weekend's
over you'll be my teaching is just
getting weird no quick work where's
Norman go where's the where's Darryl
going that'll be the last bus level 2 75
yeah you know that there's a whole look
you know the thing about Alexandria is
he didn't want to go there at all he
doesn't like anything to do with
suburbia believe um but he wanted out
and then he found a place that they can
handle him and gave him a job and he
sort of felt like he could fit in and
wanted to fit in or to fight for it and
that might go crazy later there's this
you know he's going up and down all the
time and I think he sort of finds his
safe place with these people so it gets
tested quite a bit hey what's that
walking by back there hey yeah all right
cool quick piece of business I'm like
starting to freak out daryl is walking
next week
two more pieces of business before we
wrap this up we have another another
panel to first of all Greg I'm told that
you brought a couple of exclusive
pictures that you wanted to Gavin
brought some Walker pictures you know
some of the some of the stats in the
first episode we act of season six we
did more walkers that we've done in any
episode ever so a couple a couple of
these guys you know we got a little more
rotted we actually we have one zombie
who's nicknamed the bernie wrightson
zombie so you probably get a sense of in
comic con from bernie wrightson news
really these are a couple a couple other
characters that we've done and against
we going for way more rot every year we
get more more decomposition on these
guys but first episode I we have one day
when we had 300 we had 300 walk right
directed the premiere episode coming
back by the way we r sports weekend is
90 minutes October a lot of people don't
realize that the season finale last year
was supposed to be a 60-minute episode
but Scott wrote the script the script
was so well written again you know each
premieres would have launches our
characters on to their into their
stories and then we wrap them up in the
finale so so last year's season finale
but we were cutting it together it
really we needed to wrap those stories
up so it ended up being an hour and a
half so now poor Scott and I went to
breakfast he's like so remember we did
so well that hour and a half finale what
do you think went to anything I want to
have season premiere so we have a
super-sized episode right applique
excellent and then
I'm gonna make an announcement of the
International yes um first of all we as
spina Kristin said this really is our
year to celebrate the fan and we are
also celebrating international fans and
as per usual our partners at Fox
international channels will be
premiering it in 125 countries 250
million households within 24 hours of
its us premiere so for all of you who
aren't here but have traveled a long way
you will get all these fantastic
episodes really soon after after using
the merrier excellent so you guys thank
you so much for coming out to the one
coming back up this huge in for the
entire walking dead cast and producers
sundeck over 11 we'll see you there and
then also